c'est le sénateur ump de paris pierre
charon qui répond à mes questions du
oui/non je remercie d'être là nathalie
koscuisko-morizet vous at elle convaincu
lors de notre débat hier oui
souhaiteriez-vous qu'elle mène une
campagne plus musclée oui nkm
aurait-elle pu éviter autant de
dissidence non la photo de votre conseil
national du week-end dernier a fait le
buzz tant les dirigeants de l'ump
semblait s'y faire la gueule c'est une
photo retouchée
non comment donc vous là vous l'a
certifié conforme voile absolument êtes
vous confiant par la capacité de l'ump
de reconquérir nombre de villes moyennes
oui nicolas sarkozy doit-il se soumettre
à la règle des primaires au cas très
improbable où il déciderait de revenir
en politique non c'est à dire pas de
primaires pour sarko
je pense que s'il revient c'est pas par
l'ump c'est à dire les statuts sont
adaptés à l'ump et parfois aux sans
grade à ceux qui veulent exister ce que
les primaires pour faire un petit score
et puis éventuellement être récompensés
comme le ps l'a fait le ps a fait des
primaires alors valls a été récompensé
avec 5 % en étant mise de l'intérieur
c'est à nous c'est pas du tout notre
objectif nous ne sommes pour l'homme
providentiel celui qui va nous faire
gagner ses cinq ans que nous aurons
perdu et à partir de ce moment là on va
quand même pas lomu sky et comme on dit
dans le midi pour lui faire passer des
grilles qui font qu ensuite ça va le
handicapé ne serait ce que par la
réconciliation qu'il faudra faire c'est
pas notre truc la réconciliation nous on
sait pas faire on y va cash c'est un
homme un peuple j'ai pas les primaires
vous avez reçue la petite carte postale
qui nous a envoyé de charente-maritime
au genou et c'est très bien le texte et
bien je trouve mon idée il sait bien
c'est allez vous comme d'ailleurs car la
danse et chansons aussi c'est à dire que
cette stratégie moi c'est qu'il va
pouvoir la continuer on va on va finir
peut-être par c'est à dire là on a déjà
fait un ou deux gros albums de ces
cartes postales depuis un moment on va
se lasser quand même nom qui va des
petites sorties rester confiné chez lui
ou père il évite d'aller au restaurant
parce qu'il reçoit à domicile
j'entends dans tout le monde il paraît
qu'il reçoit absolument tout le monde
les joueurs
oui les jeunes oui il dit en gros
je compte sur vous pour
comment dire faire en sorte que la
génération actuelle de l'ump passe à la
trappe vous savez à partir d'un certain
âge aussi on soutient les jeunes
monsieur field vous aussi un petit
conseil que je voudrais ensuite nathalie
kosciusko morizet elle vous a convaincu
lors de notre débat si vous me dites oui
c'est qu'elle a dû être excellent talent
absolument parce que moi je n'étais pas
au départ c'est pas mon premier choix
grâce à ses démons nazelle mon premier
choix et bournazel qu'est ce qu'il est
actuellement le plus fidèle des nkm dans
la campagne si vous dire qu'on a quand
même on les très loyaux et c'est normal
alors comme on les désigne elle est donc
vous voyez vous savez faire fonctionner
les primaires comme vous voulez oui bien
sûr mais les autres pas forcément en
tout cas tous les barons jour et casser
une image ici tous les barons la vieille
droite parisienne celle qu'on prend pour
des gens un peu curieux et derrière nkm
ils sont tous là ceux qui sont pas
d'accord et j'ai quelques amis là dedans
ce sont des jeunes pousses qui ont été
délaissés mal traités injustement
traités etc mais c'est pas grave c'est
pour le second tour que ça compte ça
fait un petit peu plus vous vous êtes un
partisan de la théorie du râteau non pas
le râteau que vous craignez la sélection
parlez vous ratisser large après vous
être plaint des dissidences vous vous
dites ça un intérêt ça va capter un
électorat qui aurait peut-être pas voter
est game au premier tome et qui votera
pour elle aux deuxièmes réserves de voix
oui je positif non si l'exploit qu'elle
a fait c'est de rajouter le centre et le
modem curieusement dans un premier temps
et en avant-garde puisque maintenant le
modem est soutenue même par l'ump
nationale concernant monsieur bayrou à
pau et c'est un gros effort pour
s'attendre d'entre nous autrefois elle
l'a fait sur paris et à partir de ce
moment là bon ça fonctionne mais si vous
me parlez des sondages défavorables
cellule on ne fait jamais de sondages je
reprends les propos du candidat
socialiste à marseille on ne comprend
jamais les sondages alors qu'il ya vingt
secteurs sur paris c'est normal que de
sondages ifop c'est la résultante de ces
vins sondages par arrondissement y en
avoir par arrondissement aucun n'a été
fait par enlisement sauf 15e et 14e y en
a pas d'autre est ce qu'elle aurait pu
éviter autant de dissidence non non il
ya toujours eu des listes dissidentes à
paris toujours henri guaino par exemple
à l'époque s'était présenté contre les
tiberi
dans le xvème il y avait une dissidence
etc et puis et puis à la fin ici dans ce
massif charles beigbeder c est quasiment
partout non c'est pour le quasiment
partout ces trois personnes c'est tout
ça que ça lui fera plaisir ben oui ça me
fait bizarre je connais très bien nous
sommes ensemble génération france c'est
curieux ce besoin chez les hommes
d'affaires de faire de la politique ou
des ce que vous ou un par le suffrage
universel on à paris n'ont pas besoin de
ça je serai beigbeder est un ami de copé
est un homme formidable quand ils
s'occupent des clubs think thank il est
fait pour ça et le peut-être le problème
connu et l'inélégance connu avec lui
c'est sûr du bonneteau en le changeant
d'arrondissement plusieurs fois c'est ça
qui l'a pas il l'a mal pris bon ben
voilà mais la politique c'est parfois
vous savez les couleuvres j'en sais
quelque chose vous pensez vraiment que
paris est gagnable rue gagnables par
l'ump c'est votre conviction l'enfant
plus que jamais je m'occupais l'ump des
villes depuis de 9000 habitants c'est à
dire celles qui doivent déposer des
dossiers pour leur financement
pour voir comment on va en gagner
actuellement dans le petit sondage que
nous avons on est à plus de 80 villes de
plus de 9000 habitants
c'est à dire comptes de campagne à
partir de ce moment là je pense aussi à
la suite de façon simple aiguille sert
au sénat qui a lieu quelques mois alors
bien sûr c'est normal d'y penser on est
à six voix d'écart malgré les triches et
les opérations multiples qui sont fait
pour changer la donne électorale on va
regagner le sénat voilà donc voilà c'est
vraiment une poussée de l'ump n'est une
moyenne de renault elles sont certes pas
bruno le maire le disais c'est une j'ai
souvent dit ici avant lui c'est que il
suffirait que marseille tentera pour que
d'un certain point de vue ça occulte une
poussée de l'ump un peu comme
symétriquement la victoire de paris et
de lyon chez les socialistes avaient
occulté le fait que c'était de très
mauvaises municipal pour le ps à
l'époque bien sûr mais actuellement on
compte quand même les villes moyennes
les petites villes les grandes villes
les moyennes villes ont contre tout ça
si paris passe à droite la soirée
et gâché pour le ps un bon lyon mais est
ce que vous croyez passage la droite où
c'est quand même très fort de monsieur
ce n'est pas le maire actuel qui est
candidat c'est madame hidalgo c'est
l'ami talgo ces policiers en train de
paris bon mon ami talgo qui est à dire
une redoutable adversaire mais un
engament je pense à sa chance face à
elle et puis elle va est aidé par un
petit gros nationale qui existe chaque
jour on a comme des bonnes nouvelles
laurent gerra le matin de quoi garnir un
petit peu vous pensez la queue leu leu
l'effet national vacant sur bien même
s'il ya on sent un micro climat parisien
qui résiste un peu au climat national
non c'est fini on est tous avec elle et
vous verrez les grandes réunions
publiques qui vont être annoncées et les
soutiens qu'elle a non mais je le sens
je disais microclimat au sens où anne
hidalgo pour l'instant ne semble pas
dire être victime du désaveu global qui
assure la politique sociale anne hidalgo
est obligé de flinguer françois hollande
qu'elle connaît bien et le parti
socialiste qu'elle connaît très bien
aussi pour espérer ne pas avoir le soul
amy d'hostilité contre elle partir de ce
moment là on est plein de bonheur nous
et plein d'espoir
parallèlement à ça vous pensez vraiment
que le sénat va revenir à la droite très
vite oui alors le sénat à bidouiller les
élections comme ailleurs cantonales
régionales bidouille toutes les
élections si on avait fait ça on ferait
tous les 20 heures c'est à dire que au
lieu dans les départements ruraux par
exemple nos élus ruraux la pensionnaire
passe de 4 à 3 donc c'est plus difficile
pour nous donc l'écart sur
représentation des élus ruraux par
rapport aux élus citadins bah je ne
pense pas non non non
donc enfin je ne pense pas chute parti
pris mais je crois bien sûr mais c'est
mon métier en même temps on passe de 6 à
16 mai avec 90 villes moyennes qui
change ce que nous espérons est ce que
nous avons compteurs actuellement je
pense qu'on change très confiant pour
les municipales donc à très confiant pas
la vague bleue c'est on dit ça parce que
booster les salles très confiant pierre
charon merci l'info continue sur lci
merci